there's a League champion that is
steadily becoming one of the most
interesting champions of all time and
last week we got a reminder of that at
Worlds wait he's taking no
damage
but blood he was taking hardly any
damage the tower shots weren't wait did
Tower shots not ramp up if you're a
minion Nico and her ability to disguise
herself as pretty much anything in the
game has made League more Dynamic to
play more unpredictable to watch and
arguably a hell of a lot more fun
[Music]
before we get into today's video we have
brand new merch check it out guess what
folks our touch grass hoodies did so
well that the suits are actually letting
us make even more dumb gamer inspired
[__] like our new Bader zipup hoodies
made for all the real blue collar
workers out there perfect for any
environment whether it's catching fish
hanging your teammates out to dry or
just tugging on your or how about are
inspiring you onward and forward te the
ideal shirt for the sweatiest of Gamers
so that you can slam the W key with zero
resistance and little to no chafing
teammates don't like it [__] them ruin
everyone's night oh and yeah we got
these blue Esports te's I forgot we made
these uh yeah they're definitely blue
and they say Esports game in style and
comfort with the score Esports dropped
to available now if you want to get your
hands on any of that check out the link
in the description box all right so for
the initiated Nico the Curious chameleon
was originally released in 2018 intended
to be a fairly standard burst Mage with
a Twist her passive inherent glamour
allowed Nico to disguise herself as an
Allied champion in order to take enemies
by surprise and bait them to their
deaths it was a really cool idea that
we'd never seen before in league but as
novel and inventive as it was Nico got
off to a rough start her pick and win
rate started off low and only got worse
this was particularly known noticeable
in Pro play where she steadily declined
in popularity from season 9 onwards by
season 12 she was picked in all pro
games globally a total of seven times
six of which she lost and she was also a
buggy mess at times who can forget NCO
turning into a turret at will and just
deleting nearby enemies I mean what the
that was absolutely insane Riot needed
to do something to save Nico from the
realm of failed gimmick champ and in
January this year they revealed their
plans so there's a lot of things going
on Nico but I can give the one sneak
peek which is her passive instead of
just turning to other Champions is now
other things anything she can turn into
a plant she can turn into a Teo mushroom
she can turn into a minion a monster and
a champion there were changes to Nico's
basic abilities and ultimate but all
eyes were on that new passive suddenly
Nico could be anything a honeyfruit
plant a Teo shroom Tibbers or even just
a humble minion in fact everyone had to
learn very quickly to count enemy
minions in approaching waves because if
there was one too many it could actually
be a ni about to [__] your [__] up even
the pros fell for this early on like
when the lpl's harder stopped an enemy
Siege by disguising himself as a minion
and waiting for the perfect moment
harder's a minion he's a cast minion
will it work will he find his
opportunity his seventh game of LPL and
to make the playo it works the on
through now hard's team might have gone
on to lose that game but the point here
is that was sick to watch the building
tension the unpredictability the new way
to break a siege that wasn't just a
front to back team fight or a TP flank
now obviously Pro and Casual players
alike weren't just picking her because
she made games more unpredictable her
kit Buffs alone made her a viable mid
laner the reaction to the rework from n
Mains were mixed some felt she did less
damage others loved the fact that her UL
now knock people up some thought the
changes were a Nerf to Casual players
and a slight buff to Skilled Nikos but
undeniably Nik became a legitimate pick
after her rework last month in High ELO
she even broke the top 10 highest win
rate midlaners out of 52 Champions not
bad for a champion that was non-existent
at the start of this year and people got
really creative with Nico 2 some players
disguise themselves as minions and built
full crit to destroy their enemies who
had no idea what the was going on I mean
just look at that at the start of the
summer season we even saw yal win Billy
Billy a team fight in the LPL by
disguising himself as a scri bloom for
almost an entire minute in order to make
a pick while his team did Baron come on
come on come on some on AR look look
look look look look at the will this
work will it work will it
work and that's what you want to
see it worked it worked and that's just
scratching the surface there have been
so many wild Nico clip since her rework
every time you think you've seen it all
she surprises You Again by breaking the
game but in a really healthy way and her
rise back into the champion mainstream
has also been reflected in Pro play
during summer this year Nico had a
staggering 64% presence in global
professional play putting her in the top
five of all Champions and has been the
second most banned Champion behind only
LeBlanc and even at Worlds this year
which is happening right now she
currently has the highest win rate of
any midlaner played more than once
that's huge now the reason she's getting
picked so much in Pro play isn't because
of her unpredictability at the end of
the day Pros want to win games not
create wacky highlight reels Nico is
genuinely a solid laner in the early
game she's a lane bully who exerts a
massive amount of pressure on her
opponent which gives her Lane prior and
allows her to roam and help out her team
on top of that haral is basically a
oneman Wombo Combo now with showmaker
showing the p power of that at Worlds
last week heated up on the rumble right
now as the extender Beam not going to
find too much pop BL him the flash picks
up two be he gets the emperess Divide
off but he's still going to die look
there are sensible nerdy maybe even
boring reasons as to why Nico is doing
well in Pro play but a byproduct of that
is we get to watch her fun passive in
action take caps for example the clip we
showed at the very start last week he
turned into a cannon minion in order to
reduce the ramped up turret damage he
would usually get from tank a turret at
level five he wouldn't be able to take
more than a couple of hits in his normal
form and yet here he was tanking it for
days wa he's taking no damage to keep
but it's with the blood he was taking
hardly any damage the tower shots
weren't wait the tower shots not ramp up
if you're a minion the tower shot did
the same damage every time now there's
been some debate this week about whether
or not this is actually working as
intended or did caps abuse a bug there
but even if right do go on to decide
it's a bug I'm not sure if they will or
not it Wasing fun it was unpredictable
it got everyone talking it got everyone
fired up you know like Esports should
look league has been around for a while
there aren't many surprises these days
for the most part when you see Champions
locked in you have a decent idea of how
exactly they're going to be played
there's nothing wrong with these plays
they're the absolute bread and butter of
League of Legends and obviously Nico has
these predictable play patterns too but
the rework to her passive gave Nico
choices that made her unpredictable to
play to play against and to watch not
only that but her ability to disguise
herself as different elements of the
game mean she is tied to them that makes
her more unpredictable if the map or
meta ever changes Nico can disguise
herself as non-epic monsters as minions
as traps as Wards as pets as jungle
plants every time one of those gets
introduced or an existing one is changed
I immediately think how will this affect
Nico she'll continue to evolve with
Summoner Rift and the wider game and
continue to throw up surprises along the
way and that's really cool Nico might
not be the best champion in the game her
presence in Pro play might slump in the
future she may still be buggy at times
even the opinion of those that may Nico
may be divided but man is she fun to
watch and honestly if League wants to
survive for another 10 years they could
do a lot worse than a few more Champions
like her
but my but my God but jeez come but man
it's she fun to watch but man but come
on man like my God what come on what are
we doing here like like be real for a
second fam like think like what I'm
trying to say is she's fun to watch